behind the look of every tesla is the
vision of one man and no it's not elon
musk you may have become aware of franz
von holtzausen when he smashed a cyber
truck window by accident
oh my god well
maybe that was a little too hard and
then the same thing happened again
oh
man softening the truck with a
sledgehammer beforehand
certainly didn't help franz von holzen
is the lead designer at tesla arguably
one of the best in the world uh anyway
welcome fronts awesome to have you guys
designing is in his blood his father was
an industrial designer in connecticut
and franz followed in his footsteps
studying industrial design at syracuse
university however while working for his
dad an intern mentioned a design school
out in la which piqued his interest so
he left syracuse two years into his
studies and enrolled at the arts center
college of design he also spent time at
its sister campus in switzerland which
exposed him to european influences he
wanted a career that focused on his love
of cars he once said it was important
for him to design products that were not
just beautiful but useful to people
quote i kind of have this belief that
you can create something beautiful and
it can be very personal but is it really
serving us as a human race it may be
serving you as an outlet for your own
personal desires but if it's not
creating a function out of that as well
is it really design
in 1992 he joined volkswagen straight
out of school to work on a top secret
project redesigning the beetle the
concept one is all but forgotten today
but in 1994 people went crazy for the
new take on the retro design it looked a
lot simpler than the beetle of the 60s
vonholzen had an eye for minimalism
early in his career he realized the look
of a car could change the way people
felt about a brand the new beetle
brought back his sense of nostalgia and
helped reinvigorate a company in decline
soon other brands decided to go retro
chrysler with the pt cruiser the mini
cooper and ford with the fifth
generation mustang after nearly eight
years at vw he moved to general motors
where he led the design for pontiac
solstice and the saturn sky although
they didn't really do well sales-wise
they were seen as really cool roadsters
pure and fun but as it turned out
working at a big car company with a huge
design team wasn't his thing as he
couldn't make the kind of impact he knew
he could make von holzes put it this way
during an interview with ashley vance
for his biography on elon musk i knew i
didn't want to die there after five
years at gm mazda came calling van holtz
hasn't produced concept cars that
reinvigorated mazda or as vonholz says
and put it to vance we brought the zoom
zoom back into the look and feel of the
car
three years later in 2008 he left mazda
for tesla
a friend had told von holzen that tesla
was looking for chief designer he
reached out to musk's assistant mary
beth brown and eventually met musk for
an interview at spacex headquarters musk
liked what he saw and sold it as an
opportunity to leave a cushy job to work
for a company that could potentially
shape the future they took a drive in
the roadster and van holtz hasn't
thought to himself as he recalled to
vance i knew i could stay at mazda for
10 years and get very comfortable or
take a huge leap of faith at tesla there
was no history no baggage there was just
a vision of products that could change
the world who wouldn't want to be
involved with that he said most of his
colleagues thought he was crazy for
joining tesla it was super risky very
few car startups succeed back then musk
only gave tesla a 10 shot of surviving
musk hired van holtz thousands
specifically to design the model s he
didn't have much to work with just a few
sketches and a clay model he knew the
model s would need to be iconic this
would be the foundation for the entire
tesla line he once said it needed to
attract people like a moth to a flame he
designed the model s in a corner of
spacex's factory and reportedly worked
on the prototype in a tent to keep away
from prying eyes musk handed over the
creative reigns to van holtzen but he
did stipulate that the model s needed to
be cool like an aston martin or a
porsche it needed to have a touch screen
as iphone technology was now all the
rage and musk knew it would soon be
commonplace but a touchscreen had never
before been installed in a car and the
ipad was still years away
musk and von holzen also drove the
engineers crazy when they insisted on a
smooth clean look for the door handles
as in they only popped out when the door
had to be opened in the end they got
their way musk also insisted on making
the body of the model s out of aluminum
rather than steel to compensate for the
heavy battery pack except car companies
in north america had no experience
producing body panels made of aluminum
aluminum is prone to cracking when it's
bent it can also develop lines that can
make it difficult to hide with paint but
the tesla engineers got it done the year
von holtz has enjoyed tesla in 2008. the
company struggled financially in fact
tesla nearly went bankrupt on christmas
eve that's why von holtz has in
desperately wanted to show the model s
to the world to get people excited about
what the company had to offer in march
2009 just six months after von holzen
joined the team tesla unveiled a gray
model s and a media event the media fond
over it wired magazine described it as a
stunningly beautiful car few knew it at
the time but the model s was far from
being ready for the road unbeknownst to
reporters the car had the base structure
of a mercedes cls according to ashley
vance the mercedes cls was the
foundation they used when working on the
s despite the work that still had to be
done tesla achieved its goal of
convincing people that it could make
beautiful electric cars and compete with
the big players like audi mercedes and
bmw the model s was a commercial success
improved to doubters there was indeed a
market for evs
the original model s was delivered in
2012 but it doesn't show its age even 10
years later it still looks pretty modern
today the newer version of the s no
longer includes the nose cone at the
front amongst other changes that was
decorative not functional so they took
it away simplifying the look even more
van holtzen's motto from the start has
been simplicity without excess which has
been baked into every tesla since
including the model 3 and will be an
integral part of every tesla to come
if you dream of building incredible
products and would like to excel in math
and science in order to do so you can
join the 11 million people who have
signed up for brilliant brilliant is an
amazing tool for learning stem in a fun
hands-on way just as the tesla team is
using neural networks to achieve
self-driving you can delve into the
world of neural networks through
brilliance introduction to neural
networks course to help push your math
skills to the next level you can learn
problem-solving techniques with your
mathematical fundamentals course or
learn the key ideas of computer science
with their computer science fundamentals
course and no coding is required
brilliant is great whether you're in
high school university or if you're
already in the workforce there are no
tests and if you ever get stuck you can
click on view explanation to see where
you went wrong to get started for free
you can head to the custom link in my
description brilliant.org
newsthink in the first 200 of you to
sign up with my link will get 20 off
brilliance premium subscription which
gives you unlimited access to all the
courses
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm